[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى حلقه جديده من
برنامج مراسلون عام على بدء الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا العداله تحاول توثيق جرائم
الحرب وبخاصه الجرائم الجنسيه المرتكبه من
قبل الجنود الروس بحق نساء ورجالا هناك
مرحبا بك لقد ذهبت الى اوكرانيا لجمع
معلومات وشهادات عن حالات الاعتداءات
الجنسيه التي تعرض لها نساء ورجال هناك
هذه الجرائم غالبا تعد من المحظورات
بالنسبه لضحاياها الذين يتجنبون الحديث
عما تعرضوا له كيف تمكنت من اقناعهم اليوم
بالحديث معك
كانت هذه هي الصعوبه في هذا الفيلم مع
شركه في اخراجه ايلونيشول والسؤال الذي
لطالما طرحناه هو كيف يمكن ان ننجح في
اقناع هؤلاء الضحايا بالحديث الينا من دون
الضغط عليهم او التسبب في معاناتهم من
جديد باعاده تذكر ممر به والاشخاص الذين
وافقوا على اعطاء شهادتهم فعلوا ذلك كنوع
من المقاومه لتجاوز مشكله الحديث عن العنف
الجنسي الذي مازال يعتبر محظورا عمليات
الاغتصاب في اوكرانيا توثيق الرعب عنوان
التقرير الذي اعده كل من مارين كورتاد
واليوني فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
اياك علينا
على الكلام بوجه مكشوف لانها لم تعد صغيره
في السن وربما لانه لم يعد لديها ما تخسره
والاهم من ذلك كله انها تريد ان تتحدث
باسم الضحايا الاخرين لانه منذ بدايه
الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا تم الابلاغ عن
العديد من حالات العنف الجنسي بحق نساء
ورجال واطفال كم عدد هذه الحالات لا احد
يستطيع التقدير كيف يمكن العثور على
الضحايا وخاصه من النساء المثقلات
والخوف من العار كيف يمكن تشجيعهن على
الكلام والبوح لتقديم شكاوى وكيف يمكن
انصافهن عبر محاكمه الجناه
ارينا دوفجان كرست نفسها للقيام بمهمه
العثور على ضحايا الجرائم الجنسيه ولتكون
صله الوصل بينهم وبين السلطات اسست هذه
الاوكرانيه جمعيه لمساعده الضحايا وهي
تجوب مع زوجها المناطق المحرره منذ الربيع
الماضي
سيقصدان هذه المره مدينه خرسون التي تقع
على خط المواجهه وسط مناطق الاشتباكات
انظر هنا كما حدث وقود لكنها مدمره
بالكامل
نعم هذا المنظر يذكرني ببوتشا
لم ياتيا الى هنا من دون التزود بالمواد
الطبيه الضروريه هي تعرف ان المغتصبات
نادرا ما يتم الاعتناء بهن وقد يكون
مصابات بالتهاب
النساء لا يتحدثن مع بعضهن عما تعرضنا له
ولا يتحدثن عن ذلك الى الطبيب ايضا
كانت خبيره تجميل قبل ان تصبح ناشطه هي
نفسها كانت ضحيه الاغتصاب عام 2014 من قبل
احد الانفصاليين الموالين لروسيا وهي تكرس
وقتها للجمعيه وكانها بذلك تريد الانتقام
لما عانته شخصيا
عندما كنت معتقلا تعرضت للاغتصاب
لقد غطوا راسي بكيس اعلم انني لن استطيع
ابدا التعرف على ذلك الرجل الذي اغتصبني
هو انه لن يعاقب ابدا
هذا اذا كان لا يزال على قيد الحياه حلمي
الا يتكرر ذلك ابدا
ليس في اوكرانيا فحسب بل في جميع ارجاء
العالم
مع مرور الوقت انشات ايرينا شبكه من
المبلغين وحدثها احدهم عن امراه قد تعرف
ضحايا
صباح
ما اجمله بثيابه الزرقاء تعيش هذه المراه
مع زوجها ومع طفل يتيم تبنته اثناء الحرب
جئت لرؤيتك لانك تتجولين في المنطقه وبما
انك تتحدثين مع السكان المحليين فلابد ان
لديك علاقات وانك سمعت ببعض الامور اريد
ان اسالك عنها نعم افهم حدثت الكثير من
الاشياء في هذه المنطقه
المحادثه تاخذ سريعا منحا غير متوقع
لقد حدث ذلك معي زوجي لا يريدني ان اتحدث
عن ذلك ولكن لقد تمت الوشايه بنا لاننا
كنا نساعد الجيش الاوكراني عندما اتى
واعتقلوني وجعلوني اقضي يومين عندهم في
القبول في البدايه كهربوني بشيء كهذا لم
اكن استطيع الرؤيه جيدا لان راسي كان مغطا
بعد ذلك فقدت الوعي لقد اغتصبوني عده مرات
انتهى الامر بالافراج عني حتى انهم ارادوا
مساعدتي
عن ذنبهم
ارينا تكتشف انها تواجه احدى الضحايا وهي
تعرف الاجراء الذي يجب فعله لكن اخبريني
هل اخبرتي المدعي العام من دون علم زوجك
بلغت المخابرات فقط
المخابرات فقط ولكن مكتب المدعي العام هو
الذي يجمع الشهادات ويتولى الملفات
في الحقيقه لم اذهب لمقابله المدعي العام
لانه كما تعلمين زوجي يتالم كثيرا لعدم
قدرته على حمايه وقتها لذلك لم اكن ارغب
في ان يحضر هذه المحادثه
ستعود ارينا في اليوم التالي لاقناعها
بتقديم شكوى
بالعوده الى مكتب المدعي العام لا يزال
القرار المتعلق بضحايا الجرائم الجنسيه
معقدا في اوكرانيا هناك اكثر من 170 حاله
تم النظر فيها حتى الان
ضحايا شعر الفتره طويله جدا بانهم تركوا
لمصائرهم في غرب البلاد بعيدا عن مناطق
المواجهات والقتال تنظم ايرين اجتماعا
لجمعيتها
جالينا التي قدمت شهادتها امام الكاميرا
قطعت مسافه 700 كيلومتر كي تروي لهؤلاء
النساء معاناتها
عندما تم تحرير قريتها بعد اسابيع قليله
من اغتصابها طلبت جالينا المساعده الطبيه
لكن في العياده عناصر المخابرات
الاوكرانيه هم الذين استمعوا اليها
[موسيقى]
طلب مني احد هؤلاء العناصر ان اخلع ملابسي
بينما كانت طبيبه النساء تجلس بعيدا في
زاويه الغرفه
عندما فتحت ساقين قال اه نعم الحاله واضحه
جدا في منطقه الاخر الصور حدث كل هذا امام
عيناي الطبيب لكنها لم تفعل اي شيء قلت
لها انا في حاجه الى علاج وطلبت اجراء
جميع الفحوص الممكنه والامراض المعديه
جنسيا اخبرتني طبيبه النساء انها لا
تستطيع ان تفعل شيئا قبل ان ادفع لها
فاقترضت المال من جاري لادفع لها
جزيلا لك على مشاركتنا قصتك لقد سلطتي
الضوء على مشكله حقيقيه
اعتبارا من الان سيكون كل شيء افضل
نعم لا باس امضيت الكثير من الوقت بمفردي
وانا الان سعيده جدا بوجودكن الى جانبيه
كل هؤلاء النساء اللواتي يدعمن جالينا
عانيناهن ايضا من العنف الجنسي ابتداء من
عام 2014 في منطقه دومباس بعد مرور ثمان
سنوات تشعر ايرينا بان الامور بدات
بالتغيير
لم يكن عدد اللواتي استطعنا التحدث عن
معاناتهن بشكل علني كبير ولم يفهم احد
وقتها ما كنا نعانيه
بداوا اخيرا يصدقوننا ويدركون حقيقه ما
حدث لنا
هل توصف العداله الضحايا يوما ما
[موسيقى]
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في لاهاي فتحت
في ادار مارس من السنه الماضيه تحقيقا حول
الجرائم الجنسيه وقد احيل ملف ايليا اليها
ايليا شاب اوكراني يبلغ من العمر 22 عاما
وقد تعرض في نيسان ابريل من السنه الماضيه
الى الاغتصاب عند احد الحواجز من قبل جنود
القوات الروسيه بعد ان عاش هذه الصدمه
حاول الانتحار عده مرات
جميع
[موسيقى]
ايليا يعرف اذا الاسم الاول لقائد هذه
المجموعه وهذا امر مهم ولكن ما رتبته وهل
كان هو من اعطى الامر او من تلقاه لتنفيذه
الاجابه عن هذه الاسئله تعتمد بالكامل على
الاجراء القانوني الذي بداه محاميه
بالنسبه الي يمكن محاكمه اولئك الذين
اصدروا الاوامر في لاهاي امام المحكمه
الدوليه
اما الاخرون الذين نفذوا هذه الاوامر
فسيمثلون امام المحاكم الاوكرانيه
ومن الممكن ان يكون عدد منهم اليوم في
سجوننا لهذا السبب علينا ان نعمل معا
لتحديد هويتي هؤلاء الاشخاص باسرع وقت
ممكن
انا متاكد من ان المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
في الهايلن تبقى صامته الا توجد فتره يمكن
ان تسقط فيها مثل هذه القضايا بالتقدم
جريمه الحرب لا تسقط بالتقادم هذا جيد
هل العنف الجنسي جزء من استراتيجيه وهل
يستخدم كسلاح حرب
بالنسبه الى المحامي السلطات الروسيه
تتحمل المسؤوليه
انا مقتنع بانه لا يوجد قرار مكتوب ينص
على اغتصاب المواطنين الاوكرانيين
سيكون الامر سخيفا ولكنه واقعي هناك
نيه في نفوسهم وفي رؤوسهم لدى بوتين
وسلطات الروسيه على اعلى المستويات بان
يصبوا الزيت على النار بتكرارهم القول ان
اوكرانيا ليست دوله وان فيها اشخاص سيئين
غير جديرين بان تحترم حقوقهم
جرائم حرب جرائم ضد الانسانيه اباده
جماعيه قد يستغرق تصنيف العداله الدوليه
لهذه الجرائم الجنسيه سنوات عديده وقد جرت
فعليا في اوكرانيا ثلاث محاكمات غيابيا
لجنود روس متهمين
اوكرانيا لا تزالوا في حاله حرب كيف من
الممكن تحقيق العداله في هذه الظروف
المدعون العامون في اوكرانيا عملهم معقد
جدا في الوقت الحالي وكذلك عمل الجمعيات
لاننا في خضم نزاع لا يزال قائما وتبعته
موجوده كصعوبه الحركه وايجاد الضحايا
وخاصه ان بعضهم ربما في وضع محرج يسعون
الى النجاه بحياتهم وليسوا مستعدين للحديث
عن معاناتهم فهم لا يعتبرون ذلك اولويه
بعضهم غادرا الى خارج البلاد وبالتالي فان
مكتبه الادعاء العام يحاول ان يجد الحلول
وان يتاقلم مع الواقع للعمل على هذه
المسائل لكي يتم ذلك في افضل الظروف
فلنستمع اذا المشاهدين الى صوت لرئيسه
مكتب المدعي العام في كييف حول هذا
الموضوع
تظهر لسوء الحظ على كامل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المشهد واضح وهو اينما يحل
جنود الروس تكون هناك جرائم ذات طابعه
جنسيه لا احد مستثنى من التعرض لها للنساء
للرجال وللاطفال
جميع المدنيين معرضون من سن الرابعه وحتى
سن ال 80 هذه الجرائم الجنسيه بالنسبه لنا
ليست حالات معزوله بل هي جزء من منهجيه
لترهيب سكان المحليين بل لسحقهم وابادتهم
نارين كورتات هل تعتقدين بان الجرائم
الجنسيه في اوكرانيا لا تحظى بالاهتمام
الكافي من قبل السلطات
في الواقع جرائم الحرب المتعلقه بالعنف
الجنسي تتضمن عده امور منها الاغتصاب
والاكراه على التعري وكل ما يجري في مراكز
الاعتقالات من تعذيب وتحديدا على الاعضاء
الجنسيه
وبالنظر الى تاريخ العداله الدوليه يمكن
التحقق من ان جميع هذه المسائل المتعلقه
بالجرائم الجنسيه يتم التعامل معها بشكل
ثانوي وقد يتم تجاهلها اذا صلب عمل مكتب
الادعاء العام الاوكراني هو النظر في هذه
الجرائم بالاهميه نفسها التي ينظر بها في
جرائم الحرب من قبل المحاكم الاوكرانيه او
المحاكم الدوليه
شكرا جزيلا لك
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام هذه الحلقه من
برنامج مراسلون شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]